hallo ich werde ihm freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft heck sind auf dem hero server
was ist mit meiner nase passiert ich
habe ein bisschen botox spritzen lassen
ich ob man da stört euch nicht mehr
vernünftig perfekt und zwar als heute
der keil mit dabei den sie gar nicht
gesagt mal irgendwas hallo bitte lauter
reden
der kreis dabei lag es nach der schule
mit zu mir gekommen wir wollten jetzt
nur der verrat für religion vorbereiten
und haben uns dann einfach mal gedacht
haben nina schoko das ist fakt ist ein
vogel
er sagt ja ich kann das töten aber ich
lasse das kommt mir die ganzen daten
bücherregal richtig schön eingerichtet
alles anders tokios aber richtig laut
gerade müssen dort leiser hier ja freuen
uns war ihr seht schon ich habe etwas
besseren shader reingepackt dank an
dieser stelle an diesen user gruppe halt
wie hier für möglich da kannte ich komme
dafür dass wir diese tollen shader hier
gegeben hast finde ich viel besser weil
das ist eine mischung aus hier nummer
eins ist ja relativ bund findet den ort
und das verwischt immer so ein bisschen
hier ne also ein bisschen zu bunt vor
allem weil dieser jahreszeit und shader
3 ist ein bisschen zu trüb finde ich
aber von den tätern hier an sich viel
besser und realistischer
dann komme ich einfach dass ich sein das
ist so eine mischung daraus und ich
finde damit sind wir ganz gut bedient
wir können immer so lassen
bild soll jetzt auch alles perfekt sein
alles passen das black chocobo und
kummer kann der kann richtig schnell
reiten kann springen und er kann sich
wehtun
mehr ist noch nicht aber er kann alles
andere sonst und das jetzt bin ich in
die guck mal der hat den kopf so komisch
kommt jetzt unser chocobo steil und da
kommen bald noch ganz ganz viele kommen
da stand dann das ist eigentlich gold
aber der ist pink gefärbt der rot
gefärbt aber da kommen bald ganz viele
coole goldene job dann haben wir alle
welche die fliegen können das sind die
besten dann ja man wie bei harry potter
das erkannt kaputt es hat sich wehgetan
alter komplett wieder hallo du siehst ja
das klappt super dieses spiel bekehrt
hat sich ist tut sich mal ein bisschen
weh dabei doch es ist auch ganz nah ist
es noch ganz jung gewesen aufwuchs da
dieses tokios echt blöd so weiter gehen
zwar hoch also können wir auch shader
per e-mail senden wenn ihr wollt com
kraft gmail.com alles andere außer diese
sachen und sowas wenn ich halt so in
folge frage wird geblockt also was wir
doch mal hier
rhein erft richtig ja mir ist ja jetzt
mal aufgefallen dass das mit den
bücherregalen nur knapp wenn ich richtig
viele bücher habe deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich in dieser folge auf
jeden fall nicht mich um bücher gefallen
werde sondern was ich machen wollte ich
habe eine liste gemacht hätte ich heute
kein internet gehabt wenn ich wieder zum
kumpel gefahren und alle die auf
facebook folgen wissen bescheid wenn ich
wieder zu den kumpeln mit stefan
gefahren und hätte den gefragt ob der
mir ob ich da wieder ein video hochladen
kann
allerdings habe ich wieder internet die
tolle telekom wieder hingekriegt haben
sogar noch bessere mutter geschickt das
heißt wenn internet ist sogar glaube ich
bestimmt beim upload 30 sekunden
schneller jetzt richtig gut von vier
stunden macht das natürlich richtig
heftig fiel aus nicht
jedenfalls soll das ganze jetzt
angeblich sogar noch besser laufen ich
weiß nicht ob ich dem ganzen glauben
schenken kann oder nicht jedenfalls habe
ich jetzt internet und hätte ich das
ehrlich kein internet gehabt hätte ich
ein video gemacht und über das dings
geredet über meine pläne exit allerdings
habe ich jetzt einfach die datei einfach
mal für diese folge jetzt vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich mir so ein paar player
macht da stehe ich aber ein paar dinge
auf jeden fall reden möchte das heißt
reden möchte ich möchte so ein paar
dinge auf jeden fall noch erreichen
in diesem projekt was er wahrscheinlich
endlos gehen wird deswegen welches
früher oder später erreichten aber egal
jolo jungs reißt euch immer denken so
fließt das wasser abfließt ab und zwar
sind also sachen bald wie ein meteor
achse dass die ganzen denn ich halte
wenig bäume ab findet dass die ganzen
items dann zu mir hin geflogen kommen
bei der materials ist das so das ist ja
so ein magnet effekt an oder mac mac
details oder irgend sowas heißt das dann
frecc0 reitsport irgendwie sowas ganz
komische sachen ich habe ein paar gute
waffe im internet zusammen gesucht und
so was alles wird auf jeden fall richtig
cool ich das ganze umsetzen kann
auch diese ganzen turbo boost hier
endlich auch auf oder
ich weiß nicht so angehäufte einmal das
ein richtiger [ __ ] zum gesagt ich
wollte hier eventuell so einen kleinen
teich dingsbums hinsetzen ist ein
bisschen mit wasser trennen sich aber
erstmal ein schokopudding ursprünglich
kann nicht von heute in der mensa und
kalt was richtig lecker gegessen werden
er musste zwangsweise was muss es zu
essen sagt nicht salat salat mit kirsch
pudding war fast ein bisschen wohl das
eigentlich selber war der schiebt die
schuld auf mich
aha ich glaube ich mache das ein
wasserfall runter oder wer das cool cool
aus
ja gut erkannt ja das stimmt entstand
war menschlich dass daran setzen dann
hier das in so kleinen fluss laufen
lassen aber irgendwie passt das auch
nicht vor recht nicht was burggraben für
ein kleines häuflein hierbei ist aber
schon gedacht das wasser fließt zu unter
dem dings her dass ich da so glas
reinmache oder so einen kleinen höhlen
gangart und daher
ich glaube es mache ich erstmal hier
kann ich das machen kann ich das machen
soll euch das glaube ich ich bin ja
natürlich angehender architekt weiß
natürlich jeder natürlich auch richtig
gut da ist es dann so gut machen kann
hier das ist ja immer noch auf der höhe
es soll ja auch eigentlich nur so
aussehen dass das dadurch schwimmt vor
mach ich das überhaupt das ist ein
blender mäßig was ich gerne mache
das sollte ja gar nicht durchkommen
eigentlich wie man hört zwar nicht aber
das ist auch besser so weit so versenkt
mal so ein vogel was er gar nicht sogar
schwimmen
das wäre genau der richtigen tieren
beste so er mit einem wasser geht das
natürlich schlecht da brauchen natürlich
mehrere wasser wasser dann kommt hier
nach einer hin
am anfang waren wir echt schon so froh
wenn wir mal so was allerdings hatten so
ein grünes chocobo lauert jetzt haben
einfach jeder ein schwarzes nahezu
schauen
es gibt auch schon zwei goldene also ich
denke von schoko fahren sind weitesten
aufgestellt es ist ja auch zombies job
hier
wie gesagt bei mir kommt wenn ich
endlich mal mein haus müssen fertig habe
dann werde ich mich auch um meine
aufgaben kümmern
baykal wir leben in einer demokratie das
ist gleich mitbestimmungsrecht nicht ich
habe eine aufgabe zugeteilt bekommen
das aufstellen der schatten verändert
sich wie gerade die so die sonne steht
da jetzt so schöne augen toki bester
mann ja ganz gut auf jeden fall jetzt
brauche ich so ein bisschen knochenmehl
habe ich gar nicht ich hab gar keinen
knochenmehl haben solche knochen wir
jetzt hier bekommen nein aus vögeln
bekommt man keinen knochen besteht da
bitte weg infos rechts das bitte weg das
macht den glanz der waffenkammer kaputt
das soll auch meile ding sein war der
blödmann mein service weg machen
ich frage ihn jetzt ob ich das auf meine
dach stellen davon irgendwie ich möchte
auch dass es bei mir vorstellen darf ich
das denn drauf meinen dach stellen
außerdem
außerdem bist doch nicht merken
aber okay ich stell zweck bis
maschinenteil ja gut kann ich irgendwie
ja okay gut
hier geht das auch klar da muss erst mal
mit inventar ausräumen wenn man nur noch
zehn minuten zeit die zeit geht immer
richtig schnell vorbei kalt das mache
ich dich traurig weil möchte einfach nur
dass jetzt das referat die macht um eine
goldene feder das auch bald kaputt mann
ist das ärgerlich neckar von hoya
sunflower ist die deka redknapp blabla
die euch noch an pflanzen
virgin kacke da kann mich packt jetzt
auch einfach mal da ich finde es so
schön mit dem shader das hast du hier so
alles so aussieht so weiß nicht was du
auch beste immer geil das spiel glaube
ich wieder ausgespielt einmal das aber
auch nur gespielt weil er wusste dass
ich davon videos machen geschichte
ich habe jetzt ein paar pläne vor
während ich hoffe freeride armor also
komplett frisur eitting wie soll dass er
geiseln fried here right click one handy
kann man nicht einfach so entscheiden
ich glaube ich mache mir die auf jeden
fall erst mich aber eine menge davon
dann meteor axt nach alten fotos mir der
meteor axt weil dadurch die items
angezogen werden die man hat also ich
mache jetzt erstmal kurze freeride am
ohr
ich weiß nicht genau was es bringt und
ob ich das jetzt lieber lassen sollte
aber zu mir hat mir soviel davon geben
da kann ich dann ja schon mal wissen was
vormachen so ich will jetzt einfach mal
an die triba sein kommen jetzt raus
ach so ich muss erstmal right click
wheel anhand damit irgendwie entscheiden
kann
ich kann jetzt einfach so hier zack zack
zack zack habe ich irgendwie enchanted
mit restauration kotoucek finity ich
dich jetzt noch in welche vorteile
ich kann damit bereits laufen gleich
eine ganze kaputt gemacht aber ich kann
damit jetzt auch nicht mehr so hoch
springen aber das eigentlich auch ganz
gut verrät bisschen lauter jahren ja wie
war der mensch seine religion ausüben
dass mein gott also desto religiöser
werte jetzt mehr kinder werdet ihr haben
mehr sex mehr region bis 6 mein gott ich
dort das schon von alleine auf jemanden
zu tauen man kacke ich möchte diese aber
nicht haben die zwar ganz schön aber
irgendwie doch nicht so fries enemies
kontingente slow down with your summer
increases underwater katic speed ach so
dass sie direkt wort hat dann alter das
also man kann damit echt schon coole
sachen machen jedenfalls was ich mir
machen wollte war ein meteor axt macht
jetzt erstmal da 143 noch zwei sticks
warum ich mir die machen wollte zeige
ich euch gleich das gerade macht aber
sind die einzigen server das projekt
relativ gut
meteor ext ach so habe ich jetzt
bisschen falsch nachgedacht ich brauche
reisen dafür wird man krank
das direktmarketing station drauf und
was all das sei gleich was man noch
machen wollte ist halt die scale aber
die fifa wollte so noch machen spaß und
ich wollte eine leckere snacks machen
würde es vielleicht gar nicht höhe
sportlich war das hier war das haben den
ball muss scheint bloodgood haye gibt es
überhaupt monk in aluminium sportback
notter ist das quatsch ich gut dass
jetzt mal einfach beim s8 rektorat der
dass solche machen das richtig gut aber
klingt das nur ich krieg das aus den
kriegs und darf erst ganz cool wenn ihr
mir das in die kommentare schreiben
könnte
was woher ich diese creighton krebs
bekommen weil weiß nicht woher bekomme
ich bei myspace blog wofür ich in den
bann des blogs sieht auf jeden fall
heftig geil aus denn die giants mord
habe ich doch ich sogar schon habe ich
darf nicht 1 ich hab nur locker sword
schade wenn ihr mir schreibt wo ich die
treppen knacken wright kacke da bekomme
das war auf jeden fall cool von euch ja
das wollte ich mir machen
dann wollte ich mir wie metal james ward
machen und da ist jetzt wieder die
fragen living metal giants wort ist
somit das beste schwert was es gibt fast
wartet das da ist mit das beste es
schwer sein aber das bekommt man nur
durch metal metal bekommt man nur wenn
man diese squeeze warte
außerdem material ich bin jetzt einfach
mal diamant weil wir in der menge
diamanten haben
ich mache mir jetzt erstmal kann auch
sein dass alles falsch machte was ich
hier zeige kann natürlich mal passieren
wieso geht das jetzt nicht so und zwar
können wir hier mit jetzt auf mops
schießen und dann bekommen wir seele von
seelen von denen unter dem diese seelen
müssen wir in einen soul keeper packen
und daraufhin haben diese sehen und aus
diesen serien kombi living metal
herstellen und ausliefern metal köln wir
dann das schwert herstellt was an so
mega op sein soll
und ja das möchte machen jetzt ebenso
helfen afrika
das center ist keeper drei ender perlen
brauche ich dafür viele habe ich euch ab
null gespielt ich habe einfach 0 einfach
keine ender perlen habe ich dann keine
ender perlen das muss sich ändern suchen
gehen oder wird jedenfalls habe ich das
dann da rein so wieder fällt mal los
tokio
ich packe dann wenn wenn das fertig ist
dann tue ich das da halt unbedingt das
wasser schwimmt auch richtig geil dass
es auch richtig gut wenn das dann dieses
welche an einem open sieger kommt
erhalten seele raus und das da muss er
mit dem seelen geber mit dem essence die
per rechtsklick drauf machen woraufhin
ich dann diesellok mal noch ein vogel
den methoden töten kann so karl witte
ja wir können um bogen die man einfach
so machen können auch einfach so töten
ok mit dir los was kaputt gegangen
da gibt's auch unter erst rot du kommst
her und dann habe ich da diese seelow
wir sind gleich am ende dann habe ich
halt diese seelen von den mops und die
kann ich dann wohl in irgendeine
konstruktionen tun wie die 90 konzeption
aussieht habe ich mir bisher nur ein
video angeguckt
ich weiß allerdings gerade nicht ganz
genau wie und es ist auch relativ dunkel
hier gerade warte kann ich nicht missen
leider wird dadurch jetzt auch nicht an
den start und so leute ich will mal ganz
kurz auf den diesen shader damit sie bei
nacht einfach mal richtig taghell ist
kommerz machen ist natürlich keinen
quatsch wie sagt man doch abstimmt
zwischen diesem shader und dem den ich
gerade die ganze zeit benutzt habe also
1 und 4
sagen wir einfach jedenfalls kann ich
damit diese seelen war gleich welches
man jetzt hier hoch junge steckt jetzt
fest oder wie für mich jetzt eingepackt
hallo frau ist behindert
jetzt geht's wenn ich an diese essenzen
habe ich schon wieder
welcher mann ich will raus aus diesem
kaff rating gefühl ich mich hier total
eingeengt welche essenzen habe kann ich
die in eine konstruktion reinpacken die
irgendwie so aussieht dass sich dann
verschiedene obsidian blöcke da drum
herum habe dann eben noch so ein
obsidian casselly damit natürlich dann
die essenzen rein und dann noch mal
irgendwas anderes und dann bekomme ich
herauslösung metal hören und dass wir
dann auf jeden fall megageil daraus kann
ich mir sogar eine op sachen machen das
ist richtig gut und ich glaube hier sind
wir in der komplett falsche richtung
nicht solltet mal lieber wieder nach
hause ist hat ein bisschen hallo hab
halt noch mehr richtig gut ich jetzt
erstmal wieder nach hause und versucht
irgendwo eine ebene zu finden ich weiß
gar nicht ob grad noch nachlässig glaube
schon
ja ich wollte endermann töten keiner so
gut gemerkt
die sache ist ich finde keine phase
fällig was die pferde bekommt man vom
band
sein wo der dings ist ja das ende der
killer kaida für die hilfe brauchen den
standort der ändern
und letztes waren ab oder beraten
schlucht hinein rasiert die richtig mit
dem instant hilfs und so weiter ich muss
jetzt schnell wieder nach hause aber
wenn man am anfang ein bisschen
gequatscht von meister sowie sind wieder
zu hause
hier müssen wir ändern sein sonst die
nächste zeit wenn wir einfach auf ändern
suche gehen
guck mal eingeladen wurde in
wirklichkeit steht da drauf
experten gehen ich verliere
da ist noch ein altbier ja die sind
stark weil diese ganzen mops getötet und
dann bekomme ich die blöden seelen von
den mops aber dafür brauche ich erstmal
drei ender perlen dahin
ich brauche ender perlen thomas die
kiste auch ender perlen ja gut ich nehme
mal wieder den anderen shader der hier
das ganze ein bisschen realistischer
erscheinen lässt er gut freuen ich würde
sagen das war's mit der heutigen folge
hero mit kaida bei der super hilfe war
wir wollten eigentlich richtig viel
schaffen haben es aber nicht hingekriegt
jedenfalls
er habe ihn geschlagen
er ist tot er ist tot
da habe ich hab so hingekriegt film
richtig jedenfalls versuchen wir dann in
der nächsten folge einfach geben immer
auf endermann suche und versuchen dann
halt richtig viele inder perlen
irgendwie raus zu kriegen aus den ganzen
ändern was ist das da eigentlich
passiert gebaut ich weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall cool aus alters sieht aus
wie eine höhle sowas so künstlich hat
angelegt vor ist die von uns konnte auch
verdammt verdammt
aber hier sehe ich gut aus nein ich weiß
kein dynamit reiner sct ja freunde dann
will ich sagen es euch gefallen würde
ich mich über einen daumen hoch auf
jeden fall freuen ihr könnt mir die
kommentare schreiben wo ich mir
kriegsschiffs gönnen kann wo ich die
irgendwie hierher kriege das parken
tokio will ich sagen ja ich muss halt
einfach der nächste folgt ein ändern und
wir brauchen einfach kraken-orakel sowie
der der typische endpunkt hoch 8
ganz klar auf jeden fall einfacher kev
jetzt blöd war zu mir du hier so freunde
fürs hotline bis zum nächsten mal
macht's gut